hello and welcome to this special
edition of spectator TV I'm Isabelle
Hoffman I'm joined by James Forsyth it
Day James hasn't it it has been a
remarkable day I think this morning last
night was chaos with all the trouble in
the division lobbies they were fracking
the Home Secretary resigning the on
offer of the chief whip had gone or not
I think it's it's never a good time when
diving street is sending journalist
messages at 1 30 am in the morning to
clarify what the situation is but I
think that was a feeling this morning
that while the situation was bad you
know lots of MPS are in Westminster
today it's a Thursday
you know maybe it wouldn't move and then
things move very very quickly
um and Graham Brady went in to see the
prime minister at the prime minister's
request and then the Deputy Prime
Minister Tres coffee who's also I think
Liz truss's closest friend in politics
uh and Jake Barry the party chairman
turned up and then the podium came out
and we all know what that means and she
announced that she had told the king
that she was planning to resign as
leader of a conservative party
and then the question became what are
the rules going to be she said the
contest would last one week and there
would be a new PM by Friday we have just
before we come on air we have heard what
those rules are they will require any MP
you want to get on the balance get a
hundred nominations that is five times
what the threshold was in the last
contest
and that means there's a maximum of
three candidates only
um at the moment we have Boris Johnson
indicating that he is interested uh no
word from him yet but he is supposed to
be flying back from his holiday and you
have MPS supportive of him you know
James Dodgers his former PPS saying you
know back you come you know the Bobby
Ewing scenario is in is in full flow uh
then suppose the rushing soon after
tweeting they are backing him again
again no word from the actual candidate
him himself
um and the Grassroots campaign Penny
Morton is is is up and running and
you've got people like Bob CD saying
that they very much hope she runs allies
of Brandon Lewis are saying that Brandon
Lewis has been urged to run but again I
mean that that 100 mp threshold is going
to be quite hard for anyone to get some
for anyone who who didn't run lost or
hasn't run for leader before because it
requires quite a lot getting 20 names is
one thing getting 100 names requires a
bit more infrastructure and it's very
rapid the MPS are going to vote on
Monday
uh and interestingly it seems that uh
there will also be that even once it is
down to two candidates those two
candidates will then run off to make
clear what their support in the
Parliamentary party is I think it is
quite clear but there are quite a lot of
MPS on the executive advantage of 22
committee who would like whoever comes
second at that point to drop out so that
there isn't the need for this online
members ballot which obviously slows
things up
but uh but you know there is no
obligation obviously on the person who
comes second not to take it to the
members
how difficult would it be to be that
sort of stitch up as some people might
call it that the members don't get a say
well I I think the question is
I think that the second place candidates
would find it difficult to push to the
members if you know they were if it was
clear that one candidate had two thirds
support with parliament passed him up
but you know if it but if it was to pick
the golden ratio 5248 for example I
think whoever was second would feel much
more inclined to say well hang on a
second we should go to the members I
think Boris Johnson will probably feel
quite inclined to say we should go to
the members on the grounds that he would
argue that he won in 2019
um and I think that but but you know and
so I think that there is this is the
dynamic that the Tory party is now
engaged in and I think that it is a
reminder that there is there are no
simple answers for the Tories here in
terms of in terms of party Unity the
reason that they couldn't find the unity
candidate which is saying what a lot of
senior back Ventures would have liked to
find is that there isn't a huge amount
of unity in the Tory party right now I
think the question is whether they can
have whether the debate can be kind of
civil or whether it all turns into a
your split the party more of an art you
know used for advice even more than I
would so it shouldn't be you you know
can they can they find a way to make
this about
policy rather than just personalities
and if it is going to be about
personalities to make it about
Personalities in a civil way the big
question that lots of people are asking
is
is Boris Johnson going to get 100
nominations he does have you know some
very vocal supporters in the party but
there have already been MPS John Barron
for instance who've gone public saying
that they would resign the conservative
whip if he became prime minister again I
think that if Morris I think if the
nomination professional will have been
set up 50 I would have said Boris
Johnson would get 50 MPS I think 100 is
is it's not been set at such a level but
it is kind of out clearly Out Of Reach
for him but it is also clearly a stretch
given that you know one of the reasons
he resigned was not just the sheer
number of ministers resigning but the
expectation if you think back to then
but the 1922 committee was going to
change the rules to allow no confidence
vote and I don't think even his closest
allies at that point brought back no
confidence vote was going to be close
that he was going to get you know 100
plus votes in that so I think we remains
to be seen I think his argument will be
um Tory MPS are very worried about the
prospect of the general election his
argument will be well look if you and
you can see Nadine Doris
his greatest cheerleader saying look you
know the way you avoid the argument for
general election is to go back to Boris
who won in 2019. he's already got um
date yeah yeah I mean the thing which is
difficult is you know there is still the
Privileges committee investigation there
are still all the reasons why he
resigned and
um I wonder what the public would think
of other kind of box that nature of of
him suddenly returning from you know to
to take out the mantle again and then I
think there are also some Tory MPS who
won um MP who will back penny more than
said to me you know look you know Boris
Johnson can't escape his role in this
you know yeah no yes he never formally
endorsed his trust but you know he let
Jacob Reese Morgan the dean Dora stand
on in Downing Street with the door
behind and you know and say that they
were backing her
um and you know the the the the the the
that he can't escape some culpability
for what has occurred
we've still got a fiscal statement
coming up on the 31st of October how is
that likely to go I mean I I think that
is inevitable but that has to be
postponed because it's not just that you
would have days but also it's it's worse
than that actually because
the obr are doing a forecast that's one
of the main reasons why this is
happening and
the measures would have had to go into
the OVR for a forecast
before the new prime minister had even
entered the building so you would
basically have the decisions that will
shape the rest of his Parliament and I
think also set the parameters to the
next election decided before a new prime
minister had even arrived
and the question that has been hovering
over the party for the past month is how
will the markets react how are the
markets reacting today how are they
likely to react to this medium-term
fiscal plan being delayed I think the
markets are relatively calm
at the moment you normally would think
that the markets would not like the
instability I mean they've been
relatively calm today because the mini
budget has to all intents and purposes
being jumped and so I think for that
reason I think you could actually say
look we've got a budget penciled in for
the 24th of November that is when all of
these things will will be decided
um and so I think that you know that is
where remains to be seen I think on
terms of uh other candidates I think
what penny Warden will pick herself as
is she will say look
um
I am I like I might be less well-known
than Boris and Rishi but
um you know that Boris supporters blame
Rishi for this Rishi supporters blind
Boris for that so why don't you go for
me to kind of jump over that hurdle
um so I think that this is we are going
to see uh like an interesting contest I
think that you know about in terms of
you know but I mean what what what those
who aren't backing many more than will
say well hang on a second one of the you
know someone who is a a Boris Johnson
aide said to me um yesterday one of the
trust's problems was that when things
went wrong she didn't have any reservoir
of support to fall back on and so there
was kind of no flaw to her support while
as you know Boris Johnson has you know
brexit for covert vaccine Rishi sunak
has the thurlo so that is obviously the
risk on the the penny more than side
Richardson United have obviously known
for a long time the challenge for him I
think is to say is you know he has
obviously been uh Vindicated in his
warnings from the summer I mean Italians
to show that um you know he can help to
bring the party back together that he
can find a way to be kind of soothing
bomb
um because obviously you know he he was
you know in that contest over the summer
which was I think what was the phrase
that Liz truss used in the BBC music
tending to be robust
um and and obviously there is the the
and the Boris Johnson's Premiership so I
I think this is the the I think that you
know I think all the candidates have
their own challenges but I mean you can
see from this timetable of 22 committee
have come up with but they want to try
and make this as quick as possible
finally do you think any of the
candidates have a realistic chance of
rescuing things to the extent that the
Tories are in with a chance of winning
the next election well I think one of
the things we've learned in British
politics recently Never Say Never
um I think that you can look at this two
ways you can either say uh
this Premiership was so brief that the
public will say right that's it we're
done with you or you can argue it was so
brief George can draw a line under it
move on and they've still got two years
to go to the next election and that
these movements in the polls have been
so dramatic but there is a kind of
almost
inherent softness to anything that moves
this fast
this March I think the other thing which
is interesting is
because of how massive his labor pole
leads are you know I suspect that that
whoever becomes a new leader and it's
probably greater for some but for more
for some candidates than others you know
they will cut that lead I'm not
suggesting they're going to cut that
lead into single digits for a second but
they will cut that lead considerably
from where it is today and the question
is whether that again gives them some
momentum which they can use to say look
you know we are we are making some
progress everyone stick together and if
we everyone sticks together we can land
the plane safely
thank you James and thank you for
watching spectator TV